All right.
Leor Stern, thank you
for being on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Good. Good.
It's my pleasure.
I am so excited to speak to you
about your journey.
Your LinkedIn says, Two-time Googler.
Not many people have that.
A lot of people have ex-Googler
or Googler.
But two-time Googler,
that's, I think, something special
that I want to hear about.
I want to hear about your experience
with the watch industry
and the smartwear.
How are we advancing
with different devices
that are in our lives,
but with technology.
And, your journey
from corporate to startup,
to another startup to corporate.
Lior, take me through a journey.
How do you get started with what you do?
Yeah, I mean, Google,
when I first joined Google in 2003,
it wasn't quite that corporate yet.
There were a couple thousand people
in the company and it was still felt.
And I think, in retrospect,
obviously was, early days.
Wow. 2003, that's wow.
Yeah. Yeah.
You know, in the story I tell,
since we're Israeli is the,
I was the first Israeli at Google
who was not either
a software engineer,
or like work in HR.
And so, the ads business in Israel
was my 20% project which completely grew.
And then I basically,
just to give you a sense
of how we did things back then,
I recruited my friends
who were in university
to help translate text strings
as we were localizing the AdWords product
into the Hebrew and local currency.
And then, as the business kept growing,
I wasn't fucking it up.
And it's always a good thing.
Yes. Yes.
And so, and I lobbied for a while
that Google should get more serious
about Israel and open an office.
And so, when we finally decided
to do that,
I was first person on the ground
to hire and train the team
and help them get set up
and integrate with Google broadly.
And then, from there, I did a similar role
building and managing a larger cluster
of the team.
What are some of the challenges
that go with bringing a business
like Google AdWords to another country?
Both, obviously, the localization of it,
but also in terms of mindset.
Looking at a whole different country,
a whole different operations.
What entails with that endeavor?
I think, it's almost like
moving countries, right?
So, it's a big logistical challenge
that contains within it
lots and lots of smaller problems, right?
So, what you do is,
you try to break down,
here's all the problems
and almost turn it into
like a step by step, kind of okay.
So, first you need to establish
a local tax entity, local legal entity,
so that you can operate in this market.
Right.
Then if you're getting paid again,
this is before Stripe.
And with every accepting foreign currency,
you ought to have largely
homegrown solutions for that.
So, you have to figure out
how to get paid,
how to establish your taxation status.
It's just basically a list of problems
that you cross off, right?
Who going to run this entity
What kind of rules do we need.
What is our business objective look like.
In the end, we had something like
150 page presentation,
that was the road map,
like the business plan
for Google in this country.
Unbelievable. Okay.
But then Lior, there's so much
that I want to cover.
So, you move on to
head of the business development at IFTTT.
Now, I have used IFTTT myself
to help me automate some processes.
And for whoever doesn't know,
IFTTT, If This Then That,
it's this idea that we can create
our own paths to productivity
and automate different processes,
integrating different applications, right?
Yeah, I know. That's exactly right.
And so, then, what does that mean
leading the business development?
After 10 years at Google,
you decide to go.
And between what you just told me,
and when you left for IFTTT,
you've done so much, obviously.
And you run business development also,
within Google for different jurisdictions.
So, but then you transitioned
to the startup life.
And what was that transition like?
So, I left Google after 10 years,
and joined IFTTT.
And when I joined IFTTT,
there were nine people on staff.
So, it was still very small.
It was, the product was well established
and still doing well.
And I love it.
But at the time,
the company was still small.
And, there were things,
by the time I left Google,
it was much bigger,
I would say that it does meet
your definition of corporate here, right?
So, I was definitely leaving
the big company life behind.
It was a little bit
like jumping off the ledge, right?
Especially having spent,
professionally,
I grew up at Google, right?
And, what I will say is,
overall the experience was there were,
I didn't find that I was that much
of a disadvantage or that I even missed
some of the big company
creature comforts and perks,
as much as I feared I might.
At the end of the day,
what you have in the snack room
or where you get your lunch is,
those things can have a cumulative effect
to optimize your working day.
But it's not like not having these things
is catastrophic.
And I also found that,
professionally and creatively
extremely liberating to come
into a much smaller environment.
And basically have to tackle problems
end to end,
and spend time thinking about
how do we impact things for our users,
how do we impact things for the ecosystem.
Rather than, how do I navigate
the internal checks and balances
and all the kinds of points of friction
that a big company has
on the way to getting something done.
Right. And then,
running business development
for small, fast growing product,
very focused, rather than dealing
within the business organization
of Google,
How does that fare?
What are the different priorities
that you have to keep in mind?
So, I think, you need
to dial up the hustle factor quite a bit,
because at a startup, it really is
much more existentially critical
that you get things done.
I think, it's also hard, even for,
if you have a hot brand,
it can still be difficult
to get mind share,
and what's most from big companies
that you're trying to partner with.
And what's most difficult,
is getting prospective partners
or customers to trust you, right?
To trust that the company will,
that there's longevity,
and that you're a good investment
of their money or time.
So, those are some
of the bigger challenges.
I think on the plus side,
startups can take bigger risks.
There's less baggage.
There's less legacy stuff to deal with.
So, even as something as simple as,
look, I'm making a call out to Nike
to suss them out about something,
you just need to find a contact
and set up time with them.
You don't need to worry about like,
well, are there other conversations
going on with Nike,
like this team working with them, right?
Which by the time I left Google,
was the case,right?
Like the're lots and lots and lots,
the breadth of activity was so vast.
So, you need to hustle more,
but there's less dissipation of effort,
if that makes sense.
And I think that's true.
I found that to be the case
as a startup CEO as well.
You don't have the advantages
of a big platform to go with,
but you also,
once you focus on doing something,
99% of your effort is just doing it,
instead of doing it
and doing your diligence,
or satisfying checks and balances,
and the things that, again,
a larger public company
has the responsibility to go through.
So, you move from corporate, to joining
the leadership of an existing company.
And then, you decide to go full throttle
on the entrepreneurship path
and create a startup yourself.
You end up selling that startup to Google,
which is actually
how you go back to Google.
And that is the two-timer.
But walk me through.
You become passionate about something
that I don't believe
you've dealt with before, right?
This whole like smart wear
and how we're interacting
with technology on our bodies.
Yeah. Yeah.
So, in my first run, I guess, at Google,
I worked on a lot of emerging
hardware form factors
and I was involved with
some mobile technologies early on.
I did a lot of work on speech recognition.
For instance, in location,
And so, when I started Chronologics,
it really was, we started the company
in late 2014.
I'd been thinking about it for a while,
but I also saw that Apple launched
the Apple Watch then.
And I became convinced that this is where
the puck was headed, right?
That wearables were going to be
a significant personal computing
form factor.
And, this was a problem
that I wanted to take part in solving.
So, that's how we came to work
on the space.
I also think, since you know IFTTT,
and by virtue of being a connector
between different products
and services, early on
I also got to spend a lot of time
with wearable companies
and creating these integrations
that allowed people to face
this flash my light disco theme
if I meet my Fitbit step count, right?
Those kinds of things.
So, I saw that there was a lot of interest
and a lot of value for users.
Not necessarily in that silly example,
but in the smart wearables.
100%.
And then, but you go then
to the more softer side.
You actually build
an operating system, right?
For wearables.
And so, you're coming in
from this business background.
The head of business development.
And you go down and you said,
"Okay, well, I'm going to actually go
and do heavy software eventually,
to be integrated onto these wearables."
Is that the traditional path for somebody
coming from business development
to then create a software based startup?
So, it's been done.
I'm much more familiar with people
starting out. For instance,
getting computer science degrees,
or starting out in the technical roles
and joining the dark side
of going into business roles.
I think that I'm a little averse to labels
and labeling people in their careers.
And I see that a lot
even as I interview people
or as a hiring manager at different times.
We have a tendency of thinking of someone
based on the job.
The last job that they've done,
or the role they've done the most of.
And I think we run the risk
of shortchanging ourselves by saying,
"Oh, I'm a business guy."
I can't speak out a product
or build a prototype of UI
for a smartwatch, for instance.
And my point is,
you never know until you try, right?.
But look, I'm not going to BS you,
I think, there's limited efficiency, right?
There's diminishing returns.
There's a strong argument to be made
for doubling down in one role.
Of course.
And I certainly have
proportionately overdeveloped
business negotiation strategy muscles
relative to some of the other things
that I needed to use as a software [--]
That's really awesome.
Now, I want you to talk to me
about this thing.
So, right now, we have so many people
walking around with these things
on their wrists.
You've been in this space
for now six years.
And you've been thinking about this daily.
And it's one of the questions
that always came up
between me and my friends
as we're seeing this world unfold
and as we're getting introduced
to this new phenomenon
of our phone on our hand,
where is the world going?
I mean, how do you see
smartwear technology
integrated into society?
And I want to play like a mind game
of where you're going to see this going
the next 10 years?
And what things we can be excited about
or pessimistic about?
Yeah. I mean, for me,
it's really a source of excitement.
Look, I think,
I'm a big believer in the notion that
computing is becoming ubiquitous, right?
So, everything around us
is becoming connected.
Doesn't necessarily mean
everything's going to have a screen
or a microphone or,
but things are going to have
sensing capabilities, inputs and outputs.
And ultimately, the world around you
is going to be a set of devices
that talk to each other.
And there will hopefully be, and I think,
you certainly see Google as being
one of the services that can help bring
all of these disparate endpoints together
to unlock value for the user, right?
To solve problems of users.
So, I think that's true in general.
And so, we're moving from a world
in which you used to sit at a computer,
and then you took your laptop with you,
and now, you've got a computer with you
all the time in your pocket.
Moving to this modality where the computer
is just ambiently around you, right?
And so, when it comes to wearables,
for me, I mean, the wristwatch dates back
to the 1600s, right?
It's in many ways the original
personal computing form factor.
And so, it's tried and true.
And there's a lot of value
in having something on your wrist.
Both as like a quick
glanceable device for interactions,
for consuming information.
And increasingly, and I think,
we're seeing this industry wide
with smartwatches
as a place to fit sensors
that can help you understand
what's going on in your body
and potentially even save your life.
So, I think, and I'm not saying
that the watch is going to eat the phone.
I don't think that's happening.
But in a broad constellation
of computing devices that you work with,
the wristwatch has these
three critical advantages to me.
One is, it works
and we're comfortable with it.
Two, a good place for sensors.
Three, good form factor
for certain interactions
and consuming information.
What's missing?
So, what's missing from my interaction
with my watch right now that you think,
I will have in the coming years?
So, I think what's missing,
there's still friction, right?
We haven't eliminated.
So, I think,
specifically things like battery life,
battery life is still quite limited.
It's another thing to charge.
Like there's some clunkiness to that.
We're still largely, I mean, I think
there are cellular connected options
for wearables, but I think,
that's still a little bit the exception.
It's expensive. It's again,
there are power implications there.
By the way, that prevention
that you mentioned before,
I'm looking at the general consumer,
when they purchase a watch,
do they use it as frequently
as they would have a regular watch?
Or does it get to a point where,
they put it away, they forget about it,
they stop using it, they come back to it.
What's the relationship
of today's consumers with wearables?
Yeah. I mean, look, I think attrition,
as with any product, is key,
and definitely the battery life.
There's a lot of data that shows that
once you have to take something off
every so often to charge it,
that can significantly increase
the chances that you're going to forget
to put it back on,
which intuitively makes sense.
So, that's definitely
a challenge that exists.
But in general, obviously,
many people are very very happy
with their smartwatches
and use them on an ongoing basis.
And there's also a link of
the fitness and wellness aspect
of these devices.
Because it's, again,
you can't get that from your phone, right.
Or certainly, not all of it
and not as easily.
And so, I think that that plays into it.
I think, there are other challenges
with the smartwatches.
I think, things new technologies,
we all had this sugar high
from the smartphone revolution,
which is a very rapid
onset transformation, right?
And then, we look at things like AI,
we look at things
like augmented reality, drones.
Like these are
technological development cycles
that are taking a little bit longer
to bear fruit.
It doesn't mean
they're not going to be monumental.
It just means that we need to be patient.
And I think, the same is true
with wearables
and with the smartwatch in particular.
I think we're still in this modality
of like developing these devices,
like a mini phone.
And as we move away from that,
we're going to see greater adoption
and ultimately, more value.
Very very cool. I have to ask,
you left Google for a few years.
And I'm extrapolating to any company
that grows naturally with time.
You come back a few years later.
You come back to the same company.
But it has to be a different company
in some sense.
Were you surprised by any social norms
or different things,
that all of a sudden, you're like,
wow, I did not expect to see this
when I came back?
Yeah. I mean, things again,
it's hard to grok
the different timelines, right?
So, like an organization evolves
at a different pace
than you experience your own career.
It was mostly the same,
I think that there were,
some positive surprises.
I think, in general,
the debate style and the team dynamics
have shifted and have been shifting
towards being nothing that was ever like
a huge problem in my first run.
But more inclusive, more just nicer,
more actively respectful.
And so, it comes with this, right?
I mean, Google, I think, worldwide
is known as one of the companies
that are very openly advocating
for healthier debate
and more supportive ecosystem
and more inclusion.
So, that comes as no surprise.
But I'm sure that it has to be
an interesting experience
living in company of X,
going through Y and Z
and coming back to W.
And then, all of a sudden,
it's like you're back in the same place,
but you've gone through all these
incredible transformations yourself.
Going through leadership at a startup.
Creating and selling a startup yourself,
and now back and working in this domain.
Leor, we're almost out of time.
I can't believe it.
But I have to ask you
the most important question.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
So, Thoughtful.
Critical.
And Helpful.
At least, yeah, that's how
I would like to describe myself.
I love it.
Leor, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
It's been a pleasure.
And just as a fun fact,
you just mentioned before this talk
that you're one of the founders
with my father and Amir, and Eyal
of Google campus, Tel Aviv, which is,
That's right.
An awesome awesome surprise to hear.
It's so fantastic.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's a funny connection.
We had Michal on the show,
Michal Waltner Levi weeks back.
And we had Amir Shevat
as our first episode.
And so, I'm slowly building the,
You're crossing the names off your list.
Exactly.
Take care. Thank you very much.
Bye. Thank you.